i hear you ancient archer too where's it
at what's the update we can talk about
it let's talk about it i've been working
on ancient archer too a lot
let me just let me just show you its
current state on github
[Music]
all right we're going to go ahead and
launch it here
so
shadows that's what i want to talk about
first we're going to go in some little
steps here all right so we're going to
go to the unit test and just run the
sunlight shadows test let's go ahead and
run this oh no i'm in the middle of
building material stuff and it's
something's broken
so we're just gonna have to comment out
some code mainly that line okay that's
not ready yet and here we have a little
sunlight shadows test so i'm gonna make
this bigger and we're gonna fly around a
little bit bass fly controls here and as
you can see there is a shadow from this
man it looks pretty jagged but that's
fine we can we can play around with that
there's another one so this is a
directional light shadow and uh the
directional light
took a lot of tweaking i'm going to talk
a lot about these little tweaks because
i couldn't really find it documented i
just had to a lot of these things i just
had to think of and test and implement
see how it went so i'll talk about them
and uh maybe they're useful maybe i uh
people already know this and i'm just
reinventing the wheel i'm not really
sure to be honest but i had to do a few
little hacks to get it to play nice um
in a more like worldwide scope because
you can do a little local scene with
shadows but if you're moving around in
like a big area you gotta like have the
light kind of follow you and i'll talk
about that a little more not technically
follow you just pseudo follow you so
these shadows actually render because
one of the problems i had was
well i wanted to figure out how to get
the shadows within a render distance and
as you can see you can back out of the
render distance here and the shadows go
away so what is happening here is the
shadows are only rendering around the
camera so basically what i had to do is
take the position of the camera and uh
basically draw around it in a kind of
hacky way all right so let's talk about
these little jaggies
and stuff so we have a light direction
we can play around with that just to
confirm it updates and it does we have
that all updating as it should be as it
changes
so it all seems to work pretty well and
the light is directly above if i flip it
to directly down below everything should
go completely dark because uh the lights
underneath uh and we can bring it back
up there we go all right we can play
with the ambient so the ambient doesn't
cast shadows in fact if we turn the
diffuse completely off and turn the
ambient all the way up we'll see that
it's just plain old lighting no shadows
or anything that's the way ambient
supposed to work so it's cool thing you
can play with i usually i don't know it
depends depends on your scene but i like
to keep it really low and just use
mostly diffuse that's really cool for
like really dark areas but there's a lot
of natural light ambient goes higher you
know but that's up to your scene so
we're going to mainly look at diffuse
specular does some things too but it's
not super noticeable you can kind of see
it it basically
if these have specular textures it will
use them if they don't it's basically
ignored um alright so render shadows we
can toggle this on or off and here is
the shadow settings that you can play
with other than the lights because this
first section is like the lights and
this is like the render setting so you
have a shadow far plane this is
basically how far it renders this seems
to be pretty good if it's about your
render distance well
i don't know for sure i was playing
around with it it seemed like 750 was a
pretty good number for what i was doing
now these biases these control the
offset of the shadow a bit and uh yeah
so you can kind of adjust those they
seem better when they're very low in
general and now these jaggies little
jaggies this ortho size will change that
i think i defaulted it to something huge
it wasn't actually 50. it was probably
like 500 i think it was 500 actually
um i just don't have this uh ortho size
thing hooked up 100 correctly apparently
but you can see you can adjust it to
something that looks good for your scene
and uh yeah that's a very sharp looking
shadow but then it doesn't render as far
so you got to have some balance here and
and play with some things because your
ortho size is bigger you can render from
further but they're not as sharp so you
could have this auto adjust based on how
far you are from things i don't know if
there's stuff like that you could do it
could get very way more complicated is
the point i'm getting to but in general
we have some settings we can play around
with them for our any given scene and
set what's best for that so it's uh
they're functional
and
that's basically it's basically all they
are is functional so that's the uh
sunlight shadows or directional light
shadows i'll show a little bit of the
code based around some of the more
unique things i did so most of this
involves the the shader that's using and
that shader code and the render process
or render graph i'm going through for
rendering shadows basically uh as long
as there is a directional light it
starts setting up things and then it
also checks and make sure that it
actually has shadows and the objects
that are in the scene actually want to
render shadows because you can toggle it
off per object as well
and if that is all true it sets it up
for the shader given the light space
matrix jumping off point from this i'll
just show you real quick just in case
you want a good getting started point it
was this site right here i went through
this tutorial to get a base
understanding i had to read it several
times there are definitely a lot of
things to shadows and you can't cover
them all in one article but this is
pretty good it gets into a lot of
details um and then i just had to adapt
it to my particular engine and setup and
all that and how i'm doing my shaders so
it had to adjust some things and i had
to i learned a few things too like the
shadows on that tutorial are for a very
small scene so you really got to get in
there and play with the ortho size and
stuff for your scene and also and when
we do the render shadows we pass in a
view pause and this view pause is the
camera that you're looking from it's
that position and the only thing it
really wants this for is for this look
at because um this is what keeps it
rendering around you basically and i
don't know this is kind of a hack so
basically you know the light direction
for this sunlight it's just a
tiny little vector from one to zero
basically it normally just sits at this
very center of your scene you know
between zero and one coordinates so we
scale it up by 200 and we also add it to
our view pause so that keeps it relative
to where we're at and that way it's uh
for all these other calculations it
keeps the shadows actually rendering
around us so that is the point of that
and uh also adjust the center to us so
the light is basically always relative
to us no no obviously it's not a hundred
percent correct technically for a
sunlight and it's more of just a hack to
keep the shadows for the directional
light specifically rendering around us
and not way off somewhere in the scene
where we can't even see um and i i don't
know i don't think i found that info
anywhere i just kind of like determined
that that was a thing i should do and
implemented it so it seems to be okay uh
yeah a lot of trial and error but uh let
me know is anyone else doing that or do
you have a different solution for
keeping the directional shadows
rendering around you and now let's talk
about the shader i have a shader in here
just called uber shader it basically
does all the core stuff it has a kind of
a default render
setup that should generally work for
just about everything so it's uh it's
kind of like the default one and uh i do
plan on later adding some specialized
ones or allowing support for people to
add their own but currently in
everything defaults to the super shader
so this uber shader basically handles uh
all a textured up object and all the
lights and all the shadows and some
reflection models and we're going to add
to it as we go like we're going to put
hdr in here and later we're also going
to be adding
materials that aren't from sampler 2ds
but are just colors because that's
another workflow that gets used and
generally for a lot of this stuff we
just have toggles or whether it has
certain things and that's used down
below in the shader to do the
calculations
so that there is the fragment or pixel
shader but there's also all the uh
the vertex shader stuff too and here's
the light calculations for the
directional light which uh as the
shadows right here uh that's basically
all we're doing and that's i think most
of this code is from that learn opengl i
did modify some things and do it my own
way a little bit just had to really
think about this light direction a lot
and uh just make sure you're doing what
you think it does there's the end of the
function
but uh i think that's about it for the
directional shadows you saw how they
look i'll run one other test that has a
bunch of them in there i don't think i
have as many settings adjustments set up
for it there we go let's try this one
lighting test okay here we go here's the
lighting test there's actually a thing
in here i forgot to do and that was
animate the
animate the whatever change the vertices
before get the new matrix for this
animation and pass it to the shadows i
forgot to do that and actually that
brings up another good point of
something else i need to do so these
calculations for all of these animations
are all currently done on the shader
and that's kind of okay in some ways but
if we ever want to get the position of
this mesh and where things are going
which will be relevant when we add
physics and colliders later
uh we actually want to do these
calculations on the cpu so i think what
i'm going to end up doing or optionally
we could move them to a compute shader i
believe so if we do all these uh
calculations for the animations on the
cpu or compute shader
then what we can do is uh pass that to
all the shaders we can pass it to the
shadows so it'll get the shadows right
and later we can also have that info
available to the physics so uh i think
we are going to have to move these
calculations off of that vertex shader
and that's when we'll fix the shadows so
that's going to happen a little later
that's why i haven't done it yet just
because i haven't done that but that is
the plan and this is just another test
scene uh this scene has a sun and it
also has
uh a bulb or point light and it also has
a flashlight which is stuck to the
camera so uh i had this scene from last
episode but if i turn down all the
lights turn off the sunlight and the
specular it's kind of interesting with
just specular but yeah let's turn it all
off now i defaulted them to 0.003 so
there's a tiny bit of light and you can
see emission textures those are still
working great the guys got an emission
texture on them all right so let's turn
up our flashlight whoa not that much
though that's a bit much there we go
wait a second i got something hooked up
wrong because look when i move this
flashlight it moves the sunlight oops
okay i need to fix that i might have
been a
a mass name replace operation that
changed both names i don't know but i
need to fix that uh real quick because
uh now i'm going to look like a goober
one sec okay what's going on here is an
i am gooey thing and it's kind of weird
so i'll talk about real quick and
basically we're just doing you know it's
i'm using very simple version of i'm
going i'm not really doing anything too
fancy but what it does is it uses this
label and if you have the same label in
several places they seem to occasionally
block together and uh weird things
happen so um
we're gonna have to give them different
names
i guess i'll just put an s after this i
don't know let's see if it likes
underscore s oh my goodness why so laggy
so i'm just gonna throw some of those in
there and uh today all right changed all
that let's hit play again and see what
happens
are they still locked together it
appears not okay very good so but these
ones still are oops uh let's rename some
more we'll just put an underscore p on
these ones for point so yeah that's a
thing gotta watch them labels and i am
gooey or else
all right let's see how we're looking
now
so let's turn down all the lights except
for our flashlight and let's turn that
to pretty bright all right so we can
walk around with our flashlight and it's
kind of like we're in like a dark cave
or something you know you can do this
sort of effect i i've still been trying
to get it to actually look like a proper
flared uh flashlight it's been hard to
get that right but uh maybe it'll
that'll come along with the hdr stuff
but for now um yeah with this kind of
setting it's kind of cool because i
don't know if you can see it too well on
the actual screen depends on your
brightness but once we get really close
you can see and uh i don't know i've
always tried to adjust it to be like a
thin beam but that seems to be really
hard to do how do you make this a thin
beam because uh i have it like as bright
as i can get it i guess i could i could
turn down this linear and quadratic a
lot and see what happens there uh but i
only have it to
0.0001 right now that should be pretty
or carry pretty far but uh yeah like
that right there should be a tiny beam
let's see if we can see it on this guy
maybe no no beam nothing all right i'm
trying to get a little dot maybe i don't
know it's not a little dot it's like a
big glow anyway the flashlight does work
but how do people get that little bright
center cone in their screen do i just
need more objects with more reflections
in the scene i don't know that's
something i'll have to address later but
it doesn't really matter the point is uh
we have all the lights working because
now we can uh turn off the flashlight or
turn it way down at least and turn on
this little spotlight which is this
rendered starting at this cube so you
can just kind of follow it around if you
want it might be hard to see on this
screen maybe i should turn up
the diffuse a bit
i don't know i could mess with this a
lot i don't know if you guys are going
to be able to see everything but the
point is the three core lights work i
still need to do shadows for the point
and the flashlight but uh not too
worried about that right now i'm gonna
do materials first and uh you know you
gotta take it one thing at a time but
shadows and lighting have been the big
focus yet again so that has generally
been my focus i didn't spend as much
time on this as i did the previous month
but i'm pretty happy with uh how the
shadows are looking there and the other
thing i did this month was i initialized
this editor so um i'm not sure exactly
what the scope of this editor is going
to be but i basically just want a little
test zone that i can load up blank and
kind of um
i don't know just use some of the tools
in so i'm working up that system it is
very primitive and hello world-ish right
now but i'll go ahead and run it and
show you what i got so basically there's
this just launches in a uh a blank a a
editor window and it turns on a drag and
drop feature so you can drag and drop
items that it supports so uh for example
if i go to my giant e drive here scroll
down past my dogecoin i'll scroll up
past my dogecoin and go to asset pack i
have a bunch of 3d models and various
things so uh you should be able to drag
in models right now and that's the only
thing i put in here so far i still got
to do properties panes and a little
widgets to move them around but i'm
going to load in this guy
and uh if we go back to visual studio
here we'll see that it's memories going
up and up and up as it does its thing
there he goes okay and he's in there i
also did add a default fly camera so you
can get around the scene you can see uh
how the model loader works for any
particular model just load them right in
he looks really creepy um but yeah you
can really get a look shadows should be
on by default as well um but yeah i'm
gonna need to get some property panes up
somewhere to adjust things and add
things and basically give you an idea of
what you're doing but uh yeah this is
like i said very hello worldy let's go
ahead and load in something else um just
to make it fill out a little bit i got
this little test ground and i'll throw
in there real quick and you can see the
shadows so everything just centers when
you throw it in there i do need to get
the widgets i can't remember what
they're called but basically just some
things to move scale rotate transform
all that's in the engine i just need to
add some more stuff for this editor but
then like what's the point of the editor
if you can't even save your work so it's
a whole big project on its own and i'm
debating whether it's really worth going
down the editor road because the reality
is i don't have time to do it all i need
to pick
a thing i want to work on most and uh
keep in that direction oh iterate on the
editor i just don't know how fast it's
going to come along and uh currently
working on materials as of right now
getting those supported and uh trying to
find the time so in other news and uh
and what's going on i'm moving so i've
been prepping to move um
locations and uh yeah i guess that's all
i'm gonna say about it so it's been
keeping me a little busier than usual
and a lot of family life stuff and i
think you know i know i say this all the
time but i really want to make a game
i'm basically making this engine to
support a game i want to make and uh
it's something i've also been iterating
on to the design of and there's several
games so
i don't know if i'm going to focus on
the game the editor or the engine or a
little bit of all three but it's
probably just gonna be a little bit of
all three and uh yeah i appreciate your
guys support i'm not sure what else to
just say about all that i don't wanna
give big spoilers and say too much and
then be like oh yeah i decided not to do
that or something you know i appreciate
you guys thanks for watching the video
good luck with all your coding stuff and
uh yeah if you want to talk more code
join the discord or sign up on patreon
or something i'll be in touch peace out
guys
[Music]
messing with some materials this is the
next phase so more render options and
more render fun
you